un ancien président tunisien visé par un
mandat d'amener international
29 marzouki accusé d'avoir porté
atteinte aux intérêts nationaux
on nous reproche notamment les propos
tenus sur des médias contre le coup de
force du président karzaï ait des le
point avec notre correspondant à tunis
ben hassen chébili
c'est une première dans l'histoire de la
justice tunisienne le bureau
d'information du tribunal de première
instance de tunis annoncé hier
l'émission d'un mandat d'amener
international contre moncef marzouki
premier président de la république
tunisienne post ben ali en cause des
propos tenus lors d'une intervention
télévisée le 12 octobre dernier sur le
plateau de france 24 l'ancien opposant
de benali se féliciter d'avoir oeuvré au
report du sommet de la francophonie
moncef marzouki en avait profité pour
appeler les autorités françaises a
rejeté tout soutien accueilli sayed qui
selon lui auraient comploté contre la
révolution de 2011 est aboli la
constitution par la mise en place de
mesures exceptionnelles à furieux le 15
octobre dernier l'actuel locataire du
palais de carthage avaient ordonné au
cours d'une réunion du conseil des
ministres l'ouverture d'une enquête
judiciaire contre ceux qui portent
atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux de la
tunisie depuis l étranger et complotent
contre la sûreté de l'état selon le
porte-parole de la cour d'appel de tunis
une enquête a été ouverte contre moncef
marzouki par ordonnance de la ministre
de la justice et par ordre du procureur
de la république près le tribunal de
première instance de tunis depuis le
coup de force du président sayed le 25
juillet dernier moncef marzouki qui
réside actuellement en france a
multiplié les interventions sur les
chaînes de télévision notamment france
24 et al jazeera pour appeler à la
destitution de celui qu'il qualifie de
putschistes ou encore de dictateurs
longtemps connu comme l'un des opposants
historiques de l'ancien président zine
el-abidine ben ali moncef marzouki
symboliser le combat pour la démocratie
en tunisie avant de voir son image
entachée par son rapprochement avec le
parti d'inspiration islamiste ennahda
moncef marzouki qui s'est vu retirer son
passeport diplomatique est devenu en
l'espace d'un mois l'un des ennemis de
la tunisie aux yeux de l'actuel homme
fort de tunis